hi there steve kaufman here again um
it's getting close to christmas
i have my uh son and his family who live
in london visiting staying with us
we're about to head off to my other son
mark's place for brunch
um but i just wanted to talk today a
little bit about
intermediate level content
and the kinds of things that i have been
doing
to find and create intermediate level
content in
the languages that i'm learning but i
think it's a great
model that i'd like to see
you know other people pick up on
so i have a
person that i'm in touch with in iran
who is creating uh content for link that
we're calling the iranians
and all it is is people talking about
themselves or one person did an episode
where she spoke about yaldo which is the
uh as she explains it in this short
lesson at link that i just finished
going through
uh it's the last day of autumn
and of course f which is like right now
you know and uh soon the days will start
getting longer again because they have
been getting shorter and this is a major
as you know festival in iran so that was
and they different foods and stuff and
that was kind of interesting another one
talks about a person and
and um you know what he's studying and
where he lives and it's just everyday
life um
i think these are
and some of them may be dialogues but
i've i've mentioned this before this
idea of having
simple language where people speak first
and then
whatever they say gets transcribed
because this ensures that the uh
the vocabulary level is going to be you
know lower or
more high frequency words and therefore
it makes it easier for us to learn from
and of course we're discovering so
hopefully we can build up
you know 10 20 30 40 of these where we
get to know
iranians uh some of them may come on
more than once in the series we have the
same thing uh now um
we're going to be offering in the new
year
uh this wonderful
range of similar material prepared by
matthew aldridge
for egyptian arabic and levantine arabic
and apparently he has some syrian arabic
in the works and we will offer these so
it will be syrian voices or lebanese or
egyptians
and
it would be nice to get the same in all
of our languages this is great
sort of material to learn from the
algerians the japanese
the russians the ukrainians the and so
people just talking about themselves in
their daily lives or talking with other
people about daily things but naturally
not scripted and then transcribed
and i think this is this fills the great
gap that i've often you know talked
about the gap between purely beginner
material
and sort of
much more demanding material like the
podcasts that i try to listen to and
and
oh and by the way in the in the podcast
again i'm going to have them transcribed
by professional
transcribers because it's simply too
difficult to deal with the automatic
transcription service it's just not
accurate enough
and
i'm going to be approaching the bbc and
uh
franz merkel and al jazeera again to see
if we can't get permission to share
these because if i have to pay to have
them transcribed i don't want to just do
that for my own use i want to be able to
share it with people at link so
at any rate
um
content is king
content is is so important to keep us
going we have to be interested is there
something new uh
in the library at link or
things that are easy that come at us and
we don't have to go and figure out how
to rip audio off you know
videos or or
go to automatic transcription services
and all this stuff that is so difficult
to do
we want to try to make it more readily
available and that's one of our goals in
the new year at link by the way is to
present the content to find more good
content and to present it in a way
that's easier for people to deal with
so basically that's uh i just wanted to
make sure i got in a video here
before charging off for brunch
and
i'm sure everyone is into their holiday
season and i wish everyone a very happy
holiday season
um
christmas or hanukkah or
uh
yaldo in iran or whatever the
corresponding uh
festival
is elsewhere it's
you know the reason
it's not unique to christmas that the
end of the year i mean the romans
celebrated the saturnalia i think it was
as you know the darkest day of the year
as we
once again turned towards a new year
where the days are starting to get
longer was typically a time when people
had festivals so happy holidays and
happy festivals to everyone
and bye for now